hello and welcome to the UCL ex deepmind
lecture series my name is Alex graves
I'm a research scientist at deep mind
and I'm going to be talking to you today
about attention and memory in deep
learning so you may have heard people
talk about attention in neural networks
and it's it's really is emerged over the
last few years as a really exciting new
component in the deep deep learning
toolkit is one of the in my opinion is
one of the last new things that's been
added to our toolbox and so in this
lecture we're going to explain how
attention works in deep learning and
we're also going to talk about the
linked concept of memory and so you can
think of memory in some sense as
attention through time and so we're
going to talk about a range of attention
mechanisms those that are implicitly
present in any deep network as well as
more explicitly defined attention and
then we'll talk about external memory
and and what happens when you have
attention to to that and how that
provides you with selective recall and
then we'll talk about transformers and
variable computation time so I think the
first thing to say about attention is
that it is not something it is it's not
only something that's useful for
learning it plays a vital part in human
cognition so the ability to focus on one
thing and ignore others is really vital
and so we can see this in our everyday
lives
we're constantly bombarded with sensory
information coming from from all
directions and we need to be able to
pick out certain elements of that signal
in order to be able to concentrate on
them so a classical example of this is
known as the cocktail party problem when
people are attending a noisy party and
listening to lots of other people
talking at once we're still easy able to
easily pick out one particular speaker
and kind of let the others fade into the
background and this is what allows us to
hear what they're saying but there's
also
kind of a form of introspective or
internal attention that allows us to
append to one thought at a time to
remember one event rather than all
events and I think the crucial thing
that I want you to the crucial idea that
I want you to take away from this is
that attention is all about ignoring
things is it's not about putting more
information into a neural network it's
actually about removing some of the
information so that it's possible to
focus on specific parts now I know
you've all heard about neural networks
and how they work and it might seem at
first glance that there's nothing about
a neural network that is particularly
related to this notion of attention so
we have this you know this is this big
nonlinear function approximated that
takes vectors in and gives vectors out
and so in this kind of paradigm attic
example you have an image coming in
being processed and then a
classification decision coming out is is
it a leopard or a Jaguar or a cheetah in
this image and this doesn't appear to
have much to do with attention at first
glance the whole image is presented to
the network and then a single decision
is made but what you can actually find
if you if you look inside neural
networks and analyze what they're
actually doing with the data is that
they already learn a form of implicit
attention meaning that they respond more
strongly to some parts of the data than
others and this is really crucial so if
you want to distinguish you know a
leopard for example from a tiger or
something like that part of what you
need to focus on are the spots in the
leopards fur and you need to do that we
need to focus on these parts while
ignoring perhaps a relevant detail in
the background and to a first
approximation we can we can study this
use of implicit attention by looking at
the network Jacobian so the Jacobian is
basically the sensitivity of the network
outputs with respect to the inputs so
mathematically it's really just a matrix
of partial derivatives where each
element j IJ is the partial derivative
of some output unit I with respect to
some in
you know J and you can compute this
thing with ordinary back prop so
basically the back calculation that's
used for gradient descent can be
repurposed to analyze the sensitivity of
the network all you do is you instead of
passing through the errors with respect
to some loss function you set the error
is equal to the output activations
themselves and then you perform back
problem and by doing this we get a feel
for what the network what pieces of
information the network is really
focusing on what it's using in order to
solve a particular pass so by way of
illustration
here's a neural network that's it's
known as the dueling network this is
from oh and architecture presented in
2015 it was used for reinforcement
learning now it's it's a network that
was applied to playing Atari games and
so the input is a video sequence and the
output in this case the network has has
a two two headed outputs one has
attempts to predict the value of the
state as it's kind of normal for
reinforcement learning of a deep
reinforcement learning the other head
attempts to predict the action advantage
so which is basically the the
differential between the value of given
a particular action and the expected
value overall or to put it in simpler
terms it tries to guess whether
performing a particular action will make
its value higher or lower and
we look at the video here this image on
the on the Left represents the the
Jacobian with respect to the value
prediction and what's being shown here
so we're seeing the the input video
itself this is a racing game where the
goal is to try and overtake as many cars
as possible without crashing and
overlaid on that this red heatmap that
we see flaring up this is the Jacobian
so the places that are appearing in red
are the places that the network is
sensitive to so if we concentrate on the
left side of this video we can see some
things that are of the network is really
interested in so one of them is it tends
to focus on the the horizon the car is
appearing you know just appearing on the
screen and of course these are very
important as a predictor of how much
score the network is likely to obtain in
the near future because it's by
overtaking these cars that it gets
points it's also continually focused on
the car itself and obviously that's
important because it needs to know its
own state in order to believe this value
and interestingly it has another area of
continual focus which is the score of
the bottom so because it's the score
that it's attempting to predict the
score is the value of these games I it
kind of makes sense that knowing what
the current score is is very important
that's what gives it an indicator of how
fast the value is is accumulating if we
look at the image on the right which is
also a Jacobian plot but this time it's
the it's the Jacobian of this action
advantage so the degree to which any one
particular action is better or worse
than the expectation over other actions
we see a very different picture first of
all we see that there's less sensitivity
over all the Jacobian these red areas of
sensitivity are a lot less prevalent and
when we do show up when they do show up
we tend to show up in different places
they're not looking so much at the
horizon they're not looking at the score
very much they tend to flare up just in
front of the car that's driving and the
reason for that is that the information
it needs to decide whether it's better
to go right or left
is really the information about the cars
that are very close to it so that's the
point it's only really when it comes
close to another car that it has this
critical decision about whether it
should go right or left and so what I'm
trying to get across with this video is
that even for the same data you get a
very different sensitivity pattern
depending on which task you're trying to
perform and so this implicit attention
mechanism is allowing it to process the
same data in two very different ways
it's seeing essentially even though it's
being presented with the same data it's
effectively seeing different things and
seeing these different things is what
allows it to perform different tasks so
once again this the whole point about
attention and the whole reason it's so
important is that it allows you to
ignore some parts of the data focus on
others and this same concept also
applies to recurrent neural networks I
think you've covered recurrent neural
networks in an earlier lecture and the
idea here is that you've got a lecture
that basically takes an input sequence
to take sequences inputs and produces
sequences as outputs and what really
makes recurrent neural networks interest
things that they have these feedback
connections that give them some kind of
memory of previous inputs and what we
really want to know
and as I said at the start of the
lecture memory can be thought of as a
tension through times what we really
want to know about recurrent neural
networks is how are they using the
memory to solve the paths and once again
we can appeal to the Jacobian to try to
measure this use of memory this use of
past information or surrounding context
and in this case I tend to refer to it
as a sequential Jacobian because what
you're really doing now instead of
getting it to a two-dimensional matrix
of partial derivatives you're really
looking at a three dimensional matrix
where the third dimension is to time and
what you care about mostly is how
sensitive is the network how sensitive
are the decisions made by the network at
one particular time to those inputs over
other times in other words what what
part of the sequence does it have to
birds that have to recall in order to
solve the task okay so to make that a
little bit more concrete we've got the
sequential Jacobian is a set of
derivatives of one network outputs of
one output at one particular point in
time with respect to all the inputs over
time so there's a time series there's a
sequence of these 2d Jacobian matrices
and what it can what you can use this
sequential Jacobian to analyze is how
the network responds to inputs that in
the sequence that are related in the
sense that they are needed together in
order to solve a particular aspect of
the past but are not necessarily
together or contiguous or close to one
another in the input sequence they may
be widely separated and so in the
example of God here this was from a
network that I worked on some years ago
that was trained to do online
handwriting recognition so online
handwriting recognition means that
someone is in this case writing on a
whiteboard with a pen that has an
infrared tracker that keeps track of the
location of the pen and is therefore
able to record a trajectory of pen
positions and it also records a special
end of stroke markers for when the pen
is lifted off the whiteboard and so this
text at the bottom shows that the the
words that the person wrote were once
having and then the the sort of this
next this next graph up on the bottom
shows how the information was actually
presented to the network so the network
actually saw was a series of these
coordinates x and y-coordinates for
these end of stroke spikes and then
above that
excuse me above that what we have is the
sequential Jacobian and now what I've
really looked at here what I'm really
interested here is the the magnitude of
the sequential Jacobus all these
matrices over time and what I'm really
interested in is is essentially the
magnitude of the matrix the magnitude of
the response of the network so of that
particular of one particular network
output with respect to the inputs that
the time and so the the network out
there chosen is the point so I should
say the task here is for the network to
transcribe this these online pen
positions and to kind of to recognize
what it was that the person wrote and
see these there's this output sequence
here where it's emitting label decisions
onz e in the space character and it
misses out the V in this case it wasn't
entirely classified or transcribed this
image correctly but the point that we
are looking at is the point where it
decides the output letter I in having
and what's really interesting if we look
at the sequential Jacobean we can see
that there is a peak of sensitivity
around here which roughly corresponds to
the point in the input sequence where
the stroke the main body of the letter I
was actually written so it makes sense
that there's a peak of sensitivity here
however we can see that the sensitivity
also extends further on in the sequence
it doesn't extend so far back in the
sequence only very slightly so that
sensitivities mostly to the end and I
believe the reason for this is that this
suffix ing the ink at the end of having
is a very common one and so being able
to identify that whole suffix helps you
to disambiguate the the letter I helps
to tell you for example that it's not an
owl in there and what's really
interesting is this peak is very sharp
peak right at the end what that
corresponds to is the point when the
writer lifted the pen off the page off
the whiteboard and went back to both the
ISO they wrote this entire word having
as one continuous stroke and their
cursive handwriting and then they lifted
the pen off the page and put a little
dot there and of course that dog is
crucial to recognizing an eye right
that's the thing that really
distinguishes an eye from an owl so
again it makes sense that the network is
particularly sensitive to that point but
it's nice to see that by analyzing this
sequential Jacobian you can you can
really get it to a quantifiable sense of
the degree to which is using particular
pieces of information and once again and
what the stress was really critical here
is that means it's ignoring other pieces
of information it's focus
those parts of the sequence that are
relevant and ignoring those that are
irrelevant and you know we can see that
this is really quite quite powerful it's
able to bridge things that are related
in the input sequence but may actually
be quite far apart
another example here comes from machine
translation now a major challenge in
machine translation is that words may
appear in a completely different order
in a different language and so we have a
simple example here where we have this
infinitive to reach at the start of an
English sentence that's being translated
into German but in German the
corresponding verb appears at the end of
the sentence and so in order to
correctly translate this the network
needs to be able to reorder the
information and from this paper in 2016
what it showed was just with a very deep
network without any any kind of specific
mechanism for rearrangement or for
attention the network was able to use
its implicit attention to perform this
this rearrangement and so what we're
seeing in the heat map on the right here
is again this idea of sensitivity is a
sensitivity map of the outputs at
particular points in the target sequence
so in the German sequence with respect
to the inputs in the English sequence
and you can see mostly there's a kind of
diagonal line because in this particular
case most of the sequence most of the
words have a more or less direct sort of
one-to-one translation but there's this
part at the end of the sequence for the
final two words in German are
particularly sensitive to the words at
the start in English so this word reach
is is there's a peak of sensitivity from
the end of the sequence and of course
this is this is once again showing that
the network is able to use this implicit
attention that it gets in some sense for
free just by being a very deep network
by being a very you know rich function
approximator is able to use that to
focus in on a particular part of the
sequence and to ignore the rest of the
sequence well
you know implicit tension is great but
there are still reasons to believe that
having an explicit attention mechanism
might be a good thing so what I mean by
the explicit attention mechanism is one
where you actually decide to only
present some of the data to the network
and you know completely remove other
parts of the data and one reason this
might be preferred of course is
computational efficiency so you no
longer have to process all of the data
you don't have to feed it to the network
at all so you can save some compute
there's a notion of scalability so for
example if you've got a fixed size what
I call a glimpse or like a Fourier ssin
where you you take in a fixed size part
of an image then you can scale to any
size image so that the resolution of the
input doesn't doesn't have to sort of
alter the architecture of the network
there's this notion of sequential
processing of static data which i think
is an interesting topic so again people
look at kind of visual example if we
have a for real
gaze moving around a static image that
what we get is a sequence of sensory
input and of course this is how images
are presented to the human eye were
always actually even if the data is
static we're always actually receiving
it as a sequence and there's reason to
believe that doing this gives can can
improve the robustness of systems so for
example there was a recent paper that
showed that networks with sequences of
glimpse or fovea attention mechanisms
for static data were more robust to
adversarial examples than ordinary
convolutional networks that looked at
the entire image of on go um last but
not least there's a big advantage here
in terms of interpretability so because
explicit attention requires you know
making a hard decision and choosing some
part of the data to look at you can
analyze a little bit more clearly what
it is the network is actually using so
we know the physical tension we've got
we've looked at the Jacobian as a guide
to what the network is looking at but it
really is only a guide it's not really
it's not a necessarily an entirely
reliable signal as to what the network
is is using and what its
was with the explicit attention
mechanisms as we'll see you get a much
clearer indication of the parts of the
data the network is actually focusing on
okay so the basic framework for what I'm
going to call neural attention models is
that you have a neural network as usual
that is producing an output vector as
always but it's also producing an extra
output vector that is used to
parameterize an attention model so it
gives some set of parameters that are
fed into this attention model I which
will describe in in a minute and and
that model then operates on some data
whether that's an image that you're
looking at or audio or text or whatever
it is and gives you what I'm gonna call
a glimpse vector and this is
non-standard terminology I'm just using
it because I think it helps to kind of
unify these these different models that
glute inspectors then passed the network
as input at the next time step and so
there's this kind of loop going on where
the network makes a decision about what
it wants to tend to and that then
influences the data it actually receives
it the next step and what that means is
that even if the network itself is
feed-forward the complete system is
recurrent it contains a loop okay so the
you know this the the way this
the way this model usually works is that
we define a probability distribution
over glimpses G of the data X given some
set of attention outputs so I said this
attention vector a and that's used to
parameterize something like the
probability of gluts G given a so the
simplest case here is we just split the
image into piles in this image on the
right here you can see there's nine
possible tiles and age is the sines
probabilities through a set of discrete
glimpses as in to a set of two each of
these tiles that's using one of these
tiles so it's just a kind of good
old-fashioned softmax function here
where the softmax outputs have the
probabilities of picking each tile and
so we can see that having done that if
we have a network that is using this
distribution what it's going to do is
you know output some distribution over
these nine tiles and then at each point
in time it's going to receive one of the
tiles as input so rather than sieving
receiving the whole input at once it's
going to keep on looking at one tile at
a time now one issue with this of course
is that it's a hard decision and what I
mean by a hard decision is it's no
longer we no longer have a complete
gradient with respect to what the
network is done basically what we've got
is a stochastic policy in reinforcement
learning the terms that were sampling
from in order to get big glimpses and we
can train this with something like
reinforced so kind of given it you know
the simple kind of standard mathematics
here for how you get a gradient with
respect to some stochastic sort of
discrete sample using reinforce and and
this is a sort of general trick here we
can use these sorts of what I'm gonna
call RL methods by which I really just
mean methods that are designed for
getting a training signal through a
discreet policy and we can sort of fall
back on these for supervised tasks like
image classification anytime there's a
non differentiable module in what we
can't do is just ordinary end-to-end
backprop and this is a assists a
significant difference between using
kind of hard attention as I described it
so far our versus
using this implicit attention that's
always present in neural networks so
generally we want to be something a
little bit more complex than just a soft
max over tiles one example that I've
kind of already alluded to is this
notion of a phobia model where you have
a kind of multi resolution input that
looks at the image takes part of the
image at high resolution so in this case
the center this square in the center
here is kind of recorded at high
resolution as basically it's mapped to
one to one
this next square out is also presented
to the network but at a lower resolution
so you can see the actual is taking
something that's maybe has twice as many
pixels as the one in the middle and some
sampling it down to something with the
same number of pixels and then the third
square out looks at the entire image
here that gives this very kind of squash
down low resolution version of it to the
network and the idea is that you're
mimicking the the effect of the human
eye where it has high kind of it has
high resolution in the center of your
gaze and much lower resolution in the
periphery with the idea being that the
information of the periphery is
sufficient to alert you to something
that you should attend to more closely
you should look at directly in order to
get a higher resolution view of it and
we can see an example of this apply it
to image classification this is from the
2014 paper where then the network was
given the cluttered and this data where
these endless these familiar endless
handwritten digits are basically dropped
in an image that has some visual clutter
and the idea here is that in order to
classify the now the image the network
has to discover the the digit within the
clutter again once again it's about
being able to ignore distractors being
able to ignore the noise and the green
path here shows the the movement of the
this foveal model through the image over
this kind of six-point trajectory that
is given well it classifies the image
and we can see for example in this on
the the example in the top row it starts
out here in the bottom corner where
there isn't much information and then
rapidly moves towards the digit in the
image and then kind of scans around the
the pictures to the right we can see the
information that's actually presented to
the network basically you know it starts
off with something where there's very
little information of image but there's
a blur over here that suggests there
might be something useful and then it
moves over to there and by moving around
the image it can build up a picture of
you know everything that's in the digit
that it needs to classify we have a
similar example here from the letter 8
where it kind of moves around the
periphery of the digit in order to
classify it so similar and so one you
might ask you know why would you bother
doing that when you can you can feed the
whole image into the network directly
and so one issue I mentioned earlier is
this idea of scalability and one way in
which a sequential glimpse distribution
is more scalable is that you can use it
for example to represent multiple
objects and Suz explored another paper
in 2014 where there were so for example
in the street view house numbers dataset
there are multiple numbers from people's
street addresses present in each image
and you want to kind of scan through all
of those numbers in order to recognize
them in order rather than just looking
at the image in a single goal although
it can also we provide applied the more
conventional image classification shown
here once again in order to classify the
image network will move its attention
around the really important parts of the
image and this gives you an indication
it allows you to see what it is in the
image that is necessary in order to make
the classification so so far we've
looked at both implicit and explicit
attention but the the explicit attention
we've looked at has involved making hard
decisions about what to look at and what
to ignore and this leads to the need to
train the network using our l-like
mechanisms it makes it impossible to
train the whole thing and then the back
prop so what we're going to look at in
this section is what's sometimes known
as soft or differentiable attention
which makes gives you explicit attention
but makes end-to-end training possible
so whereas in the previous examples we
had these fixed size attention windows
that we were kind of explicitly moving
around the image now we're going to look
at something that operates a little bit
differently and you know it's important
to realize that you know if we're if
we're thinking about a robot or
something where you have to actually
direct a camera in order to direct your
attention then in some sense you have to
use hard attention because you have to
make a decision about whether to look
left or right but for the kinds of
systems were we're mostly focusing on in
this lecture that isn't really the case
we've got all the data and we just need
to make a decision about what to focus
on and what not to focus on and so we
don't actually need to make a hard
decision about attention we want to
focus more on some regions and less on
others in much the same way that I
showed that we already implicitly do
with a neural network but we can take
this one step further than implicit
attention by defining one of these soft
attention these differentiable attention
mechanisms that we can train and to end
and they're actually pretty simple is a
very basic template so if we think back
to the glutes distribution I talked
about before where we have the
parameters of the network defining some
distribution over glimpses and what we
did then was take a sample from that
distribution and it was because we were
picking these samples that we do to
think in terms of training the network
with reinforcement learning techniques
so what we can do instead is something
like a mean field approach we take an
expectation over all possible glimpses
instead of a sample so it's just this
weighted sum where we we take all the
glimpse vectors and multiply them by the
probability of that glimpse vector given
the attention parameters and sum the
whole thing up and because it's a
weighted sum and not a sample this whole
thing is straightforwardly
differentiable with respect to the
attention parameters a as long as the
glooms distribution itself is
differentiable which it usually is so
now we no longer have you know reinforce
or some reinforcement learning algorithm
we really just have ordinary
and in actual fact because we're doing
this weighted sum we don't really
technically need a probability
distribution at all all we need is a set
of weights here so we have a set of
weights and we're multiplying them by a
attention we're multiplying them by some
set of values which are these glimpses
and and the weighted sum of these two
things gives us the attention readout
now there's I've got a little asterisk
here on the slide where I'm saying yes
we don't actually need a proper
probability distribution here but it's
usually a nice thing to have so just if
we if we make sure the weights are all
between 0 & 1 or they some the one that
everything tends to stay nicely
normalized and sometimes it seems to be
a good thing as far as changing the
network curves but anyway if we look at
this weighted sum this attention readout
V which is just now if we think stop
thinking probabilistic times and just
think of some of our eye times from some
weights I and some vectors I this should
look familiar to you it's really just an
ordinary summation a sigma network a
sigma unit from an ordinary neural
network and in fact we're where these
weights WI look like network weights so
we've gone from you know glimpse
probabilities defined by the network to
to something that looks more like
network weights and actually we can
think of attention in general as
defining something like they do
dependent dynamic weights or fast
weights is this sometimes not in there
fast because they change dynamically in
response to the data so they can change
in the middle of processing a sequence
whereas ordinary weights change slowly
they change gradually over time with
gradient descent and so to look at these
two sort of diagrams I've got here on
the Left we have the situation with an
ordinary called net where this would be
sort of a 1 1 dimensional convolutional
Network where you have a set of weights
that are given in different colors here
that are used to define a kernel that is
mapping into this this input that the
arrows are pointing into but the point
is those weights are gonna stay fixed
they're fixed the same kernel is gonna
be scanned
the same image and those weights are
over the same sequence in this case it's
one-dimensional and those weights are
only gradually changing over time and in
addition of course because it's a
convolution there's a fixed size to the
kernel so we've decided in advance how
many how many inputs that are going to
be that are fed into this kernel with
the tension we have something more like
the situation on the right so we have
the set of weights that first of all
extends can in principle extend over the
whole sequence and secondly critically
those weights are data dependent they're
their function because they're emitted
you know they're they're determined by
the attention parameters that are
emitted by the network which is itself a
function of the inputs received by the
network so these weights are responding
to the input received so they're giving
us this ability to kind of define a
network on the fly and this is this is
what makes attention so powerful okay so
my first experience of attention with
with neural networks of soft attention
with neural networks was a system I
developed some years ago now I think
seven years ago to do handwriting
synthesis with recurrent neural networks
so handwriting synthesis
unlike the handwriting recognition
networks I mentioned earlier here the
task is to take some piece of text like
this the word handwriting on the left
and to transform that into something
that looks like cursive handwriting and
basically the way this works is the
network outputs it takes in a text
sequence and outputs a sequence a
trajectory of pen positions and these
positions define the movement of or
define the actual writing of the letters
so you can think of this as a kind of
sequence the sequence problem with the
the challenging thing about it is that
the alignment between the text and the
writing is unknown and so I was studying
this problem with recurrent neural
networks and I found that if I just fed
the entire text sequence in as input and
then attempted to produce the output it
didn't work at all what I needed was
something that was able to attend to a
particular part of the input sequence
when
making particular decisions about the
output sequence so for example I wanted
something that would look at the letter
H in the input sequence and use that as
the conditioning signal for when it was
drawing a letter H and move on to letter
a and so forth so once again I needed
something that was able to pick out
certain elements of the input sequence
and ignore others and and this was
achieved with soft attention so
basically the solution was that before
the network made each predicted each
point and the the handwriting trajectory
it decided where to look in the text
sequence using a soft attention
mechanism and so the mechanism here
which is is a little bit different from
the normal attention mechanisms that you
see in neural networks that we'll talk
about later the mechanism here was the
network explicitly decided how far along
the slide a Gaussian window it had over
the text sequence so there was a kind of
I thought of it as a soft reading
network and so the weights the the
parameters mitad by the network
determined a set of gaussians this is a
shown here Gaussian functions whose
either shown here by these couple of
curves and those functions had a
particular a particular Center which
determined where they were focused on
the input sequence and on and also it
was also able to parameterize the width
of the Gaussian so kind of determined
how many of the letters in the input
sequence it was looking at and I should
say the the sequence of input vectors
here what I've shown is a series of one
hop vectors which is how they presented
the network but what these actually
correspond to is letters you could think
of this as an H here and an A here and
so forth and then what the network is
deciding is where to put these gaussians
which implicitly means once we perform
this this summation at the top here that
gives us the attention weights what part
of the Technic sequence should we look
at in order to generate the the outputs
distribution and so doing this the
network was able to produce remarkably
realistic looking handwriting
these are all generated samples and you
can see that it also generates as well
as being able to legibly right
particular text sequences it writes in
different styles and the reason it does
this of course is that is trained on a
database of networks of people who sorry
I take the base of handwriting from
people writing in different styles and
so it kind of learns that in order to
generate realistic sequences it has to
pick a particular style and and stick
with it so I'm claiming on the slide
that real people right this badly maybe
that's not quite strictly true but you
know you can see at least the the here
is a system where attention was allowing
the the network to pick out the salient
information and using that to generate
something quite realistic and so as I
said one advantage of this use of
attention is that it gives you this this
interpretability it allows you to look
into the network and say what were you
attending to when you made a particular
decision and so this heat map here what
it shows is while the network was
writing the letters shown the room along
the bottom so if the the right thing
here is that the handwriting here is the
horizontal axis the vertical axis is the
text itself and you can see where this
heat map shows is what part of the text
was the network really focusing on when
it was producing a particular when it
was predicting a particular part of the
Penan trajectory and you can see that
there's this roughly diagonal line
because of course you know there is here
a one really a one-to-one correspondence
between the text and the letters that it
writes but this line isn't perfectly
straight so the point is that some well
some letters might take you know have 25
or 30 points in them or even more others
letters might have much fewer and so
this is the whole issue of the alignment
being unknown that attention was able to
solve in this instance and so this is an
example an early example of what's now
kind of photo is location in based
attention so the attention is really
about just where how far along the input
sequence you should look and so it's
important what's kind of interesting
here is to see what happens if you take
that attention mechanism of way and just
allow the network to generate
handwriting on
and this was very similar to the result
I obtained when I first tried to you to
treat this task as a more conventional
sequence the sequence learning problem
where the entire sequence was fed to the
network at once and what happens is it
generates things that kind of look like
words that kind of look like letters but
don't make much sense and of course it's
August the reason for this is that the
the conditioning signal isn't reaching
the network because it doesn't have this
attention mechanism but allows it to
pick out which letter it should write at
a particular time okay so that was a
sort of an early example of a neural
network with soft attention but the form
of attention that's really kind of taken
over the one that you'll see everywhere
in neural networks now as what I think
of as associative or content-based
attention so instead of choosing where
to look according to the position within
a sequence of some piece of information
what you can do instead is attend to the
content that you want to look at and so
the way this looks is that works is that
the network the attention parameter
emitted by the network is a key vector
and that key vector is then compared to
all the elements in the input data using
some similarity function so typically
you have something like a cosine
similarity or something that involves of
taking a dot product between the key and
all the elements in the date in the data
and then typically this is M normalized
with something like a softmax function
and that gives you the attention weights
so you know implicitly what you're doing
is you're you're outputting some some
key you're looking through everything in
the data to see which parts of the data
most closely match to that key and
you're getting back a vector an
attention vector that focuses more
strongly in the places that that are
more that are closer that correspond
more closely to the key and this is a
really natural way to search you can
actually define you can do you can
essentially do everything you need to do
computationally just by using
content-based lookup and what's really
interesting about it is that it
especially with this sort of cosine
similarity measure it gives you this
multi-dimensional feature based lookup
so you can put
a set of features corresponding to
particular elements of this key vector
and find something that matches along
those features and ignore other parts of
the vectors so just by sending other
parts of the vector to zero you'll get
something that matches on particular
features and doesn't worry about others
so it has it gives this this
multi-dimensional very natural way of
searching so for example you might want
to say well show me an earlier frame of
video in which something red appeared
and you can do that by specifying the
kind of red element in your the
representation of your key vector and
then the associative attention mechanism
will pick out the red things
so typically what's done now is is given
these weights you can then perform this
this expectation that I mentioned
earlier where you sum up over the data
you compute this kind of this weighted
sum and you get an intention readout
what you can also do and this has become
I think increasingly popular with
attention based networks is you can
split the data into key value pairs and
use the keys to define the attention
weights and the values to define the
readout so there's now a separation
between what you use to look up the data
and what you're actually going to get
back when you read it out and this has
been used I mean as I said this is now
really a fundamental building block of
deep learning and it was first applied
in this paper from 2014 for neural
machine translation and once again so
similar to the heat map I showed you in
previous slide for implicit attention we
have something here that shows what the
network is attending to when it
translates in this case from I believe
it's translating from English to French
or it might be from French to English
and what's kind of interesting here you
can see first of all if we compare this
to the earlier heat map I showed for
implicit attention it's clear that the
decisions are much sharper so you get a
much stronger sense here of exactly what
the network is attending to and what
it's ignoring um secondly in this case
there's a more or less one-to-one
correspondence between the English words
and the French words apart
from this phrase European Economic Area
that is reversed in French and you can
see this reversal here in the image by
this kind of line that goes sort of
against the diagonal of the rest of the
sequence and so this is this is a very
as we'll see this is a very powerful
general way of allowing the network in a
differentiable antenna trainable way
allowing the network to pick out
particular elements of the input data
here's an example of a similar network
in use here the task is this is the the
task is to determine what this this this
removed symbol is in the data so if we
look at the example on the Left we have
so B I should say the proper names have
been replaced by numbered entities here
which is quite a standard thing to do in
language processing tasks because proper
names are very difficult to deal with
otherwise and we have this this task
where entity 1 one-line identifies the C
singer as X and what the network has to
do is to fill in X and you can see from
this heat map here which words it's
attending to when it attempts to fill in
this X and you can see it's mostly
particularly focused on this entity 23
which was presumably the decision it
made and which is indeed correct it says
he was identified Thursday as Special
Warfare operator and the d23 in general
it's focusing on the entities throughout
because it can kind of tell that those
are the ones that it needs to look at
and read answer these questions
similarly X dedicated their fall fashion
show - mums you can see it's very
focused on this particular entity here
is helping it make its decision and and
what's really crucial here is that
there's a lot of text than this piece
there's a lot of text that it's ignoring
but it's using this content based
attention mechanism to pick out specific
elements and this can be taken is this
you know attention mechanism this
combination typically of a recurrent
neural network with attention can be
used much more broadly it's been applied
to speech recognition for example and
here we see a plot not dissimilar to the
one I showed you for handwriting
synthesis where we have
an alignment being discovered between
the audio ratings and there is a
spectrogram and the text sequence that
the network is is outputting the
characters that it's using to transcribe
this data so for example that was this
long pause at the start when nothing
happens Network mostly ignores that it
knows that when it has to start emitting
for example the s T you start with the
sentence it's very focused on these
sounds at the beginning corresponding to
those two those noises in the speech
signal so basically this attention
mechanism is a very general gives a very
general purpose technique for focusing
in on particular parts of the data and
this is all done with well mostly all
done with content-based attention okay
so another form of so there are a huge
number of possible attention mechanisms
and we're only going to mention a few of
them in this talk and one idea I want
you to leave you with is that there's a
very general framework here having to
find this attention templates that gives
you this weighted sum there's lots of
different operators you could use to get
those those attention weights and one
very interesting idea from a network
known as draw for 2015 the idea was to
determine an explicitly visual kind of
soft attention so this is kind of
similar to the phobia models we looked
at earlier only instead of an explicit
and of hard decision about where to move
this this phobia around the image rather
there was a set of Gaussian filters that
were applied to the image and what these
did is they have a similar effect of
being able to focus in on particular
parts of the image anymore other parts
but it's all differentiable end to end
because there's a filter that is being
applied everywhere that gives you these
attention weights and what does this
filter look like well if you look at
these three images on the right we show
that four different settings of the
parameters for the Gaussian filters the
filter variants essentially the you know
the width of the filter the center the
stride as we've shown here with which
the filter is applied throughout image
also this last parameter for intensity
by varying these we get different views
of the same letter v so this one here is
quite focused in on this central part of
the image this one here is looking more
at the image as a whole and it's doing
so with quite low variants so it's
getting quite a sharp picture of this
image this one on the bottom here is
getting a more kind of blurred like less
distinct view of the entire image and so
we can see a video of drol Network in
action what we're seeing here the
movement of these green boxes shows the
attention of the network I'm just going
to play that again
it's rather quick the attention of the
network as it looks at an endless digit
and you can see that it starts off kind
of look attending to the whole image and
then very quickly zooms in on the digit
and moves the box around the digit in
order to read it and it does a similar
thing when it starts to do generate
theta it's
it uses so this red box shows
attention is as its generating with
agent once again it starts off kind of
generating this kind of blurred out view
of the whole image and then focuses down
on a specific area and kind of it does
something that looks a lot like it's
actually drawing the image it's actually
using the attention mechanism to trace
out the strokes of the digit and so
again what's nice about this so we have
something that's kind of transforming
excuse me transforming a kind of static
task into a sequential one where there's
this sequence of Association decisions
being sre this sequence of glimpses or
views of the data and what's nice about
that is that we get this generalization
so we can now generate because it
generates these images kind of one part
at a time it can be extended to
something that generates multiple
multiple digits for example within the
same image and this is a sort of a
general an illustration of this general
property of I think scalability that are
referred to for engine mechanisms so far
what we've talked about is attention
applied to the input data being fed to
the network but as I mentioned at the
start of the lecture there's another
kind of attention which I think of as
introspective or kind of inward
attention where we as people use our
kind of user kind of cognitive attention
to pick out certain thoughts or memories
and in this section I'm going to discuss
how this kind of attention can be
introduced to two neural networks so as
I've said in the previous slides what we
were looking at was attention to
external data so deciding where in a
text sequence to look which part of an
image to look at and so forth but if we
sort of apply this attention mechanism
to the network's internal state or
memory then
we have this notion of introspective
attention and as I've said a way I like
to think about this is that memory is a
tension through times a way of picking
out a particular event that may have
happened at some point in time and
ignoring others once again just want to
come back to this idea that attention is
all about ignoring things it's all about
what you don't look at and so there's an
important difference here between
internal information and external
information which is that we can
actually modify the internal information
so we can do selective writing as well
as reading allowing the network to use
attention to iteratively modify its
internal state and an architecture that
I and and colleagues deepmind developed
in 2014 did exactly this we called it a
neural Turing machine because we what we
wanted was something that resembled the
the action of a Turing machine is the
ability to read from and write to a tape
using a neural network by a an attention
set of attention mechanisms I'm going to
talk about this architecture in some
detail because it shows it gives you a
sort of nice insight into the the
variety of things that can be achieved
with attention mechanisms and it shows
how it really shows this link between
attention and memory so the controller
in this case is a neural network it can
be recurrent or it can be feed-forward
once again even if it's feed-forward the
combined system is is recurrent because
there's this loop through the attention
mechanisms and then we have we referred
to the attention modules that are
parameterized by the network as heads
and so this was in keeping with the with
the Turing machine in analogy the tape
analogy this is something that I think
has been has been picked up in general
people often talk about attention heads
and
you know these are these these heads our
attention mechanisms or soft attention
mechanisms in the same kind of template
that we've discussed before and their
purpose is to select portions of the
memory the memory is just this real
value matrix it's just a big grid of
numbers that the network has access to
and the key thing is different is that
as well as being able to select portions
of the memory to read from these these
heads can also selectively write to the
memory so yeah once again this is all
about selective attention we have to we
don't want to modify the whole memory in
one go maybe you know I should I should
stress here the key part of the kind of
designing decision underlying the neural
Turing machine was the separate out
computation from memory in the same way
as it's done in a normal digital
computer we didn't want so for a normal
recurrent neural network for example in
order to give this is the more memory
you have to make the hidden state larger
which increases the amount of
computation done by the network as well
as giving it more memories a computation
and memory are kind of inherently bound
up in an ordinary network and we wanted
to separate them out we would have
potentially quite a small controller
that could have access to a very large
memory matrix in the same way that a
small array of a processor in a digital
computer can have access to you know a
large amount of RAM or disk or other
forms of memory and and so it's key you
know if you look at in that from that
perspective it's key that it's not
processing the entire memory at once
if this thing's going to be large it
needs to selectively focus on parts of
it to read and write and so we do this
basically using a similar the same
template as I mentioned before for soft
attention the controller the neural
networks outputs parameters that
basically parameterize this what we're
calling a distribution or awaiting over
the rows in the memory matrix but is it
this waiting is really just the same
attention weights that we discussed
before and we had
two main attention mechanism so I've
mentioned in in the previous section
that my my first experience of soft
attention in neural networks was around
location-based attention as was a ID for
this handwriting synthesis Network which
was in fact the inspiration for the
neural Turing machine so having realized
that the handwriting synthesis Network
could selectively read from an input
sequence I started to think of what
would happen if we could write to that
sequence as well and wouldn't it then
start to resemble a neural Turing
machine um but as well as the
location-based content that was
considered in the handwriting synthesis
Network this also incorporates content
based information attention which as
I've said is the kind of the the
preeminent form of attention as used in
neural networks so dressing by content
looks a lot like it does with other
content based networks is the key vector
emitted by the controller that is
compared to the content of each memory
location so each row in memory and treat
that as a vector and then we compare the
key to that vector using the similarity
measure which wasn't the cosine
similarity which we then normalize with
the softness we also introduced a extra
parameter which isn't usually there for
content-based attention which we called
sharpness and this was used to sort of
selectively narrow the focus of
attention so that it could really focus
down on individual rows in the memory
but we also included this notion of
addressing by location and the way this
worked was that the network looked at
the previous waiting and put a shift
kernel which was just a sort of a soft
max of numbers between plus and minus N
and we then essentially convolved that
with with the waiting with the the
previous waited waiting from the
previous time step to produce a shifted
waiting so basically the mass your very
simple as shown below and what this
thing is it just essentially shifted
attention through the the memory matrix
shifted it bounds if you started here
and
I'll put a shift colonel focused around
maybe five steps or so then you'd end up
with intention and attention
distribution that would look like this
and so this combination of addressing
mechanisms the idea behind this was to
allow the controller to have different
modes of interacting with the memory and
we thought about these modes as
corresponding to data structures and
accessors as I used in sort of
conventional programming languages so as
long as the content is being used on its
own the memory is kind of being accessed
the way it would be in something like a
dictionary or an associative map
well not strictly like a dictionary
because we didn't have key value
attention for this network although you
could define it um rather it would be
like an assault more like an associative
array through a combination of content
and location what we could do is use the
content-based key to locate something
like an array of contiguous vectors in
memory and then use the location to
shift into that array the shift index a
certain distance into the array and when
the network only used the location based
attention is essentially iterated it
acted like an iterator just moved all in
from the last focus so it could
essentially read a sequence of inputs in
order so basically reading we as we've
said this network uses attention to both
read from and write to the memory
reading is very much the standard
attention sort of soft attention
template we get a set of weights we get
a set of rows in the memory matrix to
which those you know that are that are
to which the network is attending and we
compute this this weighted sum so we
take each row in the metrics and
multiply it by the weight which gives
the sharpness of attention that agreed
to which the network is attending to
that particular row so this is just very
much this is exactly like the the soft
attention that I described soft
attention template I described before
only it's being applied to this
memory matrix rather than being applied
to some external piece of data
the part that was kind of novel and
unusual was the the right head the
writing attention mechanism used by
neural Turing machines and so in this
case we kind of inspired by the way long
short-term memory
LS TM has sort of forgets and and input
gates that are able to to modify the
contents of memory the contents of its
own internal state we defined a combined
operation of an arrays vector E which
behaves sort of analogous Li
equivalently to the forget gate in long
short-term memory and an ADD vector
which behaves like the input gate and
essentially what happened is the once
the the right head had determined which
rows in the matrix it was attending to
these the contents of those rows were
then selectively erased according to E
and I should say here so E is basically
a set of numbers between 0 & 1 so
basically if if some part of the erase
vector goes to 1 that means whatever was
in the memory matrix at that point is
now is now white set to 0 and if E is
set to 0 then the memory matrix is left
as it is so once again there's this kind
of smooth or differentiable analogue of
what is essentially a discrete behavior
the decision of whether or not to erase
and adding is more straightforward it
just says well take whatever's in memory
and adds whatever's in this add vector a
multiplied by the the the write weights
so basically if the right weight is high
and you're strongly attending to a
particular area in a particular row in
the matrix then you are going to
essentially add whatever is in this add
vector to that to that row and if the
white right vector the important thing
here is if if this WI for all the rows
in the matrix for which this WI is very
low nothing happens
nothing changes so if you're not tending
to that part of the memory you're not
modifying it either so how does this
work in practice so what we what we
really looked at was well can can can
this neural cheering machine learn some
kind of primitive algorithms in the
sense that we think of algorithms is
applied on up on a normal computer and
you know in particular does having this
separation between processing and memory
enable it to learn something something
more algorithmic than we could do for
example with a recurrent neural network
and we found that it was indeed able to
learn it's a very simple algorithm so
the simplest thing we looked at was a
copy task so basically a series of
random binary vectors were fed to the
network list that's shown here we
started the sequence and then the
network just has to copy all of those
and output them to through the the
output vectors now all it has to do is
just exactly copy what was in here to
what's over here so it's an entirely
trivial algorithm that would be you know
very uninteresting it's not it's not
interesting in its own right as an
algorithm but what's surprising about it
is that it's difficult for an ordinary
neural network to do this so neural
networks generally are very good at
pattern recognition they're not very
good at exactly sort of remembering
storing and recalling things now it's
exactly what we hope to add by including
this access to this memory matrix and so
the algorithm that it uses well a kind
of pseudocode version for it here is
given on the right but we can also
analyze it by looking at the use of
attention and the way it depends the
particular places in the memory during
during this task and so these two heat
maps that are shown here at the bottom
are again heat maps showing the the
degree to which the network is attending
to that particular part of the memory so
when it's black it's being ignored when
it's whitelist focusing and you can see
that there's a very sharp focus here
which is what we want because it's it's
it's basically implementing something
that is really fundamentally a discrete
algorithm and so what it does in order
to complete this copy pass is it picks a
location in memory
given here and then starts the Wrights
whatever input vector comes in
essentially just copies that to a raw
memory and then uses the location based
iterator this location based attention
you just move on one step to the next
grow memory and then it copies the next
the next equipment so forth until it's
finished copying them all and then when
it has the output it uses its low
content based lookup to locate the very
start of the of the sequence and then
just iterates through until it's copied
out everything remaining and so you know
just once again what was really
interesting here was to be able to get a
kind of an algorithmic structure like
this going through a neural network you
know it was completely parametrized by
neural network and was completely
learned and to end um and there was
nothing sort of built into the network
to adapt it towards this sort of this
sort of algorithmic behavior and so the
real issue is and actually a normal
recurrent neural network analysis the
end model Alice TM network for example
can perform this task you feed it in a
sequence of inputs and ask you to
reproduce them as outputs just as a
sequence the sequence learning problem
but what you find is it will work
reasonably well up to a certain distance
but it won't generalize beyond that so
if you train it the copy of sequences up
to length 10 and then ask it to
generalize the sequences up to length
you know 100 you'll find it doesn't work
very well as we'll see whereas with the
neural Turing machine we found that it
did work quite well so in this these
heat maps here we're showing the targets
and the output so basically this is the
the copy sequence given to the network
if it's doing everything right the each
block at the top exactly matches each
block at the bottom and you can see that
it's not perfect like there's some
mistakes creeping in as the sequences
get longer so this is for sequences you
know short sequences like 10 20 40 so on
but you can still see that most of the
sequence is still kind of retained like
most of the targets are still being
matched by the outputs in the network
and that's because it's just basically
performing this algorithm and using that
to generalize the longer sequences so
this is an example of where attention
and being able to selectively pick out
certain parts of information ignore
others gives you a stronger form of
generalization and so that that this
this form of this kind of generalization
that we see with no Turing machines does
not happen with you know a normal LSD
end model for example essentially it
learns the copy up to ten and then after
ten it just goes completely awry it
starts to it sucks the output random
mush and this really shows that it
hasn't learned an algorithm it's rather
kind of hard-coded itself has learned
internally to store these ten things in
some particular place in its memory and
it doesn't know what to do when it goes
beyond that so in other words because it
lacks this attention mechanism between
the network and the memory it's not able
to to kind of separate out computation
from memory which is what's necessary to
have this kind of generalization and so
this can be extended we look at other
tasks well one very simple one was to
learn something akin to a for loop so if
the network is given a random sequence
once it's then also given an indicator
telling it how many times it should
reproduce that output sequence and then
it just has to output the whole sequence
end times copy end times and so
basically what it does is just uses the
same algorithm as before except now it
has to keep track of how many times its
output the whole sequence so it just
keeps on jumping to the start of the
array with content based you know to a
particular row in memory using content
based location then iterates one step at
a time gets to the end and jumps back
and meanwhile it has this sort of
internal variable that keeps track of
the number of steps that it's done so
far another example of you know what it
could do with memory was this Engram
inference task so here the
is that a sequence is generated using
some random set of Engram transition
transition probabilities so basically
saying given some binary sequence given
the last three or four inputs there's a
set of probabilities telling you you
know whether the next input will be a0
or a1 and those probabilities are sort
of randomly determined and then you
generate a sequence from them and what
you can do as the sequence goes on you
can infer what the probabilities are and
there's there's a you know a sort of a
Bayesian algorithm for doing this
optimally but what we're sort of
interesting is well how well does a
neural network manage to do this how
well does it sort of it's kind of like a
meta learning problem where it has to
look at the first part of the sequence
work out what the probabilities are and
then start making predictions in
accordance with those probabilities and
what we found was that yes once again
Ellis team can kind of do this but it
doesn't do it in a very kind of it makes
quite a lot of mistakes I've indicated a
couple of them with red arrows here
oh no sorry excuse me those red arrows I
think actually indicate mistakes made
but the neural Turing machine but in
general the the neural Turing machine
was able to sort of perform this task
much better and the reason it was able
to do that is that it used its memory
use specific memory locations to store
variables that count of the occurrences
of particular Engram so if it had seen 0
0 1 for example it would use that to
define a key to look up a place in
memory might be this place here and then
the next time it's all 0 0 1 it would be
able to increment that which is
basically a way of saying okay if I've
learned that 0 0 1 is a common
transition that means that the
probability of one followed by of to 0
is followed by a 1 must be really eyes
and basically it learns to count these
occurrences which is exactly what the
optimal Bayesian algorithm does and it
uses it is able to do this by being able
to pick out selective specific areas in
its memory and use those as counters ok
so here's a little video kind of
showing the system action so this is
being performed this repeat and times
tasks or the start here where the
network is going quickly we see what
happens during training then we have the
system everything slows down here we
have you know what happens with a
chained version the network the input
data comes in while the input data was
coming in we saw this this blue arrow
here which showed the input data being
written to the network memory one step
at a time so it's stored this input
sequence in memory and then the writing
task begins once the writing task begins
we see this red arrow which represents
the the right waits the attention the
attention parameters used for writing
and we can see that these are you know
very tightly focused on one particular
row in the network the one that it's
admitting as output at any one point in
time and it's then iterating through
this array one step at a time and what
you can also see as this video goes on
is that the the sorry the the size of
the circle size and colors of the
circles here represent the magnitude of
the variables within this memory matrix
I believe they're sort of the hot colors
are positive and the cold colors are
negative as I remember
but as what's happening as the network
is looping through this whoops is
running through this loop several times
just from that video again and we can
see during training that you know at
first these attention these these these
read and write weights are not sharply
focused they're blurred out so this
sharp focus kind of comes later on once
the network is finished writing the
whole the whole sequence it then sort of
you see this these variables in the
background become larger and that's
because it's using those to keep count
of how many times it's being through the
how many times it's repeated this copy
operation and then at the end the
changes this this this final this row at
the bottom
which is an indicator the network that
is that the task is complete so it's
using this memory to kind of perform an
algorithm here and so quickly I'm just
going to mention we following the neural
Turing machine we introduced the kind of
extended version of a successor
architecture which we call
differentiable neural computers and we
introduced a bunch of new attention
mechanisms to provide memory access and
I'm not going to go through that in
detail but just to say one of the rather
than looking at algorithms with this
sort of updated version of the
architecture what we were really
interested in was looking at graphs
because so while recurrent neural
networks are designed for sequences in
particular many types of data were
naturally expressed as a graph of you
know nodes and and links between nodes
and because of this this ability to
store information in memory and the
store and recall with kind of something
that came into random access it's
possible for the network to store quite
a large and complex graph in memory and
then perform operations on it and so
what we did during training of the
system is we looked at random randomly
connected graphs and then when we tested
it we looked at specific examples of
graphs so one of them was the graph
representing the zone 1 of London
Underground and we were able to ask
questions like well can you can you find
the shortest path between war Gate and
Piccadilly Circus or so or can you can
you perform a traversal when you start
an Oxford Circus and follow the central
line and the circle line and so forth
and it was able to do this because they
could store the graph in memory and then
selectively kind of recall elements of
the graph similarly we asked it some
questions about a family tree where it
had to determine complex relationships
like maternal great-uncle and order to
do that it had to keep track of all the
links in the graph so for the for the
remainder of the lecture we're going to
look at some further topics in attention
and deep learning so one type of deep
network that's got a lot of attention
recently is known as
transformer networks and what's really
interesting about transformers as
they're often known from from the point
of view of this lecture is that they are
they really take attention to the
logical extreme they basically get rid
of everything else the all of the other
components that could have been present
in similar deep networks such as the
recurrent state present in recurrent
neural networks convolutions external
memory like we discussed in the previous
section and they just use attention to
repeatedly transform a data sequence so
it's a the idea that the paper that
introduced transformers was called
attention is all you need and that's
really the the fundamental idea behind
them is that this this attention
mechanism is so powerful it can
essentially it can essentially replace
everything else in a deep network and so
the attention the form of attention used
by transformers is is a little it's it's
mathematically the same as the attention
we've looked at for before but the way
it's implemented in the network is a
little bit different so instead of there
being a controller Network as there was
in the neural Turing machine for example
that emits some set of attention
parameters that are treated as a query
rather what you have is that every
vector in the sequence emits its own
query and compares itself with every
other and sometimes I think of this as a
sort of emergent or anarchist attention
where the attention is not being
dictated by some central control
mechanism but is rather arising directly
from the data and so in practice you
know what this means is you have quite a
similar calculation to quite quite a
similar attention mechanism to the
content-based attention we've discussed
previously where there's a cosine
similarity calculated between a set of
vectors but the point is that there's a
separate key being emitted for every
vector in the sequence that's compared
with every other and like as with NTM
endian see there are multiple attend
heads I use in fact every every point in
the input sequence gives not just one
[Music]
one set of not just one attention key to
be compared with the rest of the
sequence but several so I'm not gonna go
very much into the details of you know
how transformers work the although the
attention mechanism is straightforward
the actual architecture itself is fairly
complex and actually I recommend this
blog post the annotated transformer for
those of you who want to understand it
in more detail but if we look at the
kinds of the kinds of operations that
emerge from the system is very
intriguing so as I've said there's this
the the idea is that a series of
attention mechanisms are defined so
transformers I should say are
particularly successful for natural
language processing and I think the
reason for that and the reason that
recurrent neural networks for attention
were also first applied to languages
that in language this idea of being able
to attend to things that are widely
separated in the input is particularly
important so there's one word at the
start of the paragraph might be very
important when it comes to understanding
something much later on in the paragraph
there may be if you're trying to extract
for example the the sentiment of a
particular piece of text there may be
several words that are very well that
are very spaced out that are required in
order to make sense of it so this is
sort of a it's a natural it's a it's a
natural fit for attention based models
so in this particular example here from
the paper we see that when the so the
network has has processed has created
keys and and vectors for each element in
the input sequence and then and this
creates a you know a sequence that the
sequence of embeddings equal to length
of the original sequence and then this
process is repeated at the next level up
so the network basically now now
finds another set of key vector pairs at
every point along the sequence and those
key vector pairs are then compared with
the original embeddings to create these
attention masks and so we see for this
word making here this is being this is
being while this word is being processed
I forget what the exact task was here
while this well this word making was
being processed it was attending to a
bunch of different words laws 2009 the
word making itself but also this this
phrase more difficult here at the end of
the sequences all of these things are
are tied up with the semantics of how
this word making is used in the sentence
and generally what you find is you get
these these difference as I said there
are there are multiple attention vectors
being defined for each point in the
sequence and what you get are different
patterns of attention emerging so for
example in this example here and this is
showing the kind of the all-to-all
attention so how the embedding
corresponding to each word in the
sentence at one level is attending to
all of the embeddings at another level
and we see that this one is doing
something quite complex it seems to be
looking for phrases or what the word
what is kind of attending to this is
what the law the word law is attending
to the law and it's and so forth so
there's some kind of some you know
complicated integrating of information
going on whereas here another one of the
sort of attention masks for the same
network we see that it's doing something
much simpler which is it's just
attending to nearby words and so the
overall effect of having all of these
access to all these attention mechanisms
is that the network can learn a really
rich set of transforms for the data but
what they realize is the transformer
networks that just by repeating this
process many times they could get in a
very very powerful model in particular
of
language data and so from the original
paper they already showed that you know
the the the transformer was achieving
state-of-the-art results with machine
translation since then has kind of gone
from strength to strength you now
provide state of the Arts for language
modeling has also been used for for
other data types besides language it's
been used for speech recognition it's
been used for two-dimensional data such
as images but from this this blog post
here this was this was posted by by open
AI in 2019 we can see just how powerful
a transformer based language model can
be so in language modeling essentially
just means predicting iteratively
predicting the next word and a piece of
text or the next sub word symbol and so
in this case once the the language model
is trained it can be given a human
prompt and then you can generate from it
just by asking it to predict what word
things will come next and then feeding
that word in and repeating this whole
transformer based network that is able
to attend to all of the previous context
in the data and what's really
interesting about this text relative to
texts that have been generated by
language models in the past is that it
manages to stay on topic is that manages
to keep the context intact throughout a
relatively long speech a relatively long
piece of text so having started off
talking about a herd of unicorns living
in an unexplored valley in the Andes it
continues to talk about unicorns it
continues to it keeps the setting
constant in the Andes Mountains it you
know vents a biologist from the
University of La Paz and once it's made
these inventions for example once it's
named the biologist it keeps that name
in fact I haven't called it Perez once
it knows to keep on calling on Paris
throughout and the reason it can do that
is that it has this really powerful use
of context that comes from having this
this ability to attend to everything in
the sequence so far so what what
attention is really doing here is
allowing it to span very long very long
divides very long separations in the
data this is something that even you
know before attention was introduced
even the most powerful recurrent neural
networks such as LST M they struggled to
do because they had to store everything
in the internal state of a network which
was constantly being overwritten by new
data so between the first time
Perez is introduced in the last time
there might have been you know several
hundred updates of the network and this
information about Paris would attenuate
during these updates but attention
allows you to kind of remove this
attenuation it allows you to bridge
these very long gaps and that's really
the secret to to its power particularly
for language moment and so one
interesting extension to so they should
say there have been many many extensions
to transformer networks
and they kind of you know go on from
strength to strength particularly with
language modeling and one one extension
that I'd like to look at in this lecture
which I find very interesting is known
as universal transformers so the idea
here is that the the basically the
weights of the transformer are tied
across each transform so the transforms
you if we look at this model here if we
have the input sequence over time along
the x-axis then this the effect of the
transform is to generate a set of of
self attention masks at each point
belong the sequence and then all of the
the embeddings associated with these
points are then transformed again the
next level up and so on now in an
ordinary transformer these parameters
that happen the the parameters of the
attention the the self attention
operations
are different at each point going up at
each at each transformer each level
going up on the y-axis and this means
that the the functional form of the
transform is being enacted is different
at each step so tying these weights
going up through the stack makes it act
like a recurrent neural network in
deaths so what you have is something
like a recursive transform and what's
interesting about that is that you then
start to have something that can behave
a little bit more algorithmically
something that is not only very good
with language but is good at learning
the sorts of functions the sort of sort
of algorithmic behaviors that I talked
about in the neural Turing machine
section and so this could be seen from
from some of the results for universal
transformers where it was applied for
example to the baby tasks which are a
set of kind of toy linguistic tasks
generated using a grammar and so a
related topic to this idea so there's
this idea here of this having a
recursive transform and oh and the other
thing I should say is that because the
way it's divided it means you can you
can enact this transform a variable
number of times in just the same way
that you can run an RNN through a
variable length sequence so now we have
something where the amount of time it
spends transforming each part of the
data and can become variable it can
become data dependent and so this
relates to work that I did in 2016 which
I called adaptive computation time the
idea of adaptive computation time was to
change so with an ordinary recurrent
neural network there's a one-to-one kind
of correspondence between input steps
and output steps every time an input
comes in the network and it's an output
and the problem with this in some sense
is that ties it ties computation time to
what we could call data time there's one
pick of computation for every step in
the data and now you can you can
alleviate this by stacking
the layers on top of each other so now
you have multiple takes a computation
for each each point in the input
sequence but the idea of adaptive
computation time was that maybe we could
allow the network to learn how long it
needed to think in order to make each
decision we call this the amount of time
it's spent pondering each decisions the
idea is some network some input comes in
at times the x1 the network receives a
hidden state it's hidden state from the
previous time step as usually the
recurrent neural network and it then
thinks for a variable number of steps
before making a decision and and this
variable number of steps is determined
by a halting probabilities these numbers
of might reading up like 8 the idea is
that when that probability passes a
threshold of 1 the network when the sum
of these probabilities passes the
threshold of 1 the network is ready to
emit an output and move on to the next
time step and so what's the sort of the
relevance of this mechanism to the rest
of this lecture which has been about
more explicit attention mechanisms is
that in some sense the amount of time a
person or even a neural network spends
thinking about a particular decision
that it makes it's strongly related to
the degree to which it attendance to it
so there have been cognitive experiments
on with people where you can you can by
measuring the amount of time it takes
them to answer a particular question you
can sort of measure the amount of
attention that they're needing to give
to that question and so if we look at
this concretely if we look at what
happens with this adaptive computation
time if we apply this to a recurrent
neural network this is an ordinary lsdm
network that is being applied to
language modeling in this case next step
character prediction and this what this
graph is showing is the the y-axis shows
the number of steps that the network
stop to think for now this number of
steps is actually not it's not integer
because there's
there's this question where it can it
can it can slightly overrun a complete
step but that's not really important
what's important here is that there's a
variable amount of computation going on
for each of these predictions that it
has to make and you can immediately see
a pattern so for example the amount of
ponder time goes up when there's a space
between words and the reason for this is
that it's at the start of words that we
need to spend the longest thinking
because it's it's basically it's easier
once you've gone most of the way through
a word it's easy to predict the ending
once you've seen P OPL is pretty easy to
click the P is gonna come next once you
see a space after that e then it becomes
harder now you have to think well and
the many people what word could come
next so this takes a little bit more
fall and then it tends to drop down
again and it spikes up even further when
it comes to a kind of larger divider
like a full stop like a comma so there's
this very close if we think about if you
think back to the the plots I showed you
at the very start of this lecture were
to do with the visitor tension where we
saw that a deep network or recurrent
neural network will concentrate in some
sense or will respond more strongly to
certain parts of the sequence we kind of
see that same pattern emerge again when
we give it a variable amount of time to
think about what's going on in sequence
and there's some interesting
consequences here so for example one is
that the network is only because this is
this is a question of how long it needs
to take in order to make a particular
prediction the network is only
interested in predictable data so for
example if you see these IV tags this is
from Wikipedia data which contains you
know XML tags as well we can see that
the network is law there's no spike in
instead of thinking time when it comes
to these ID numbers this is kind of
interesting because these ID numbers are
hard to predict so it isn't simply that
the network thinks longer whenever you'd
find something that's harder to
Hey it thinks longer when it sort of
believes that there's a benefit to
thinking longer when thinking longer is
likely to make it better able to make a
prediction and the reason it would be
better able to make it a prediction is
that it allows it to spend more time
allows it to spend more time processing
the context on which that prediction is
based and so this kind of goes back
again to the idea we talked about in
transformers of having these repeated
steps of both contextual processing as
being the thing that builds up the
information the network needs to make a
prediction and so there's a nice
combination of this this idea of
adaptive computation time with these
universal transformer models and so in
this case here we have a task from the
baby data set where there's a series of
sentences so these these sentences as
entered along the x-axis are kind of
like the input from the network then or
these are the contexts that the network
needs to know about and then it gets
asked the question the question here was
where was the Apple before the bathroom
and if you go through all of these
sentences now I think I've cropped this
grass it doesn't have all of them but
you can see that things are happening
with the Apple John dropped the Apple
John grabbed the Apple John went to the
office so I think the Apple at this
point is probably in the office John
journey to the bathroom well maybe now
it's gone to the bathroom in between
those two things where some pieces of
information that weren't relevant
sandwich the milk for example John
traveled to the office were back in the
office again so there's a little puzzle
here that the network has to work out as
to where the Apple has ended up and of
course some parts of this sequence are
important for that puzzle and some parts
are John discarded the Apple there well
of course that's very important
basically all of the ones that mentioned
where John is are important and
generally those are the ones that the
network spends longer thinking about so
we're kind of via this adaptive
computation time and bhayya this
transformer model where you know and
every second time each point along the
sequences
pending for all of the others but we
build up a similar picture in some sense
to the one we had at the start of the
lecture where we can see that the
network has learned to focus more on
some parts of the sequence analysis so
once again this is what attention is all
about is about ignoring things and being
selective and so to conclude I think the
main point I would like to get across in
this lecture is that selective attention
appears to be as useful for deep
learning as it is for people as we saw
at the start of the lecture implicit
attention is always in present in some
degree in neural networks just because
they learn to become more sensitive for
certain parts of the data than to others
but we can also add explicit attention
mechanisms on top of that and it seems
to be very beneficial to do so these
mechanisms can be stochastic so-called
hard attention that we can train in
reinforcement learning or they can be
differentiable so-called soft attention
which could be trained with ordinary
backprop in Indian learning and we can
use attention to attend to memory or to
some internal state of the network as
well as to data so many types of
attention mechanism have been defined
and I should say that even the ones are
covered in this lecture only or only
cover a small fraction of what's being
considered in the field and many more
could be defined and I think and what's
become you know very clear over the last
few years is that you can really get
excellent results state-of-the-art
results in sequence learning by just
using attention by using transformers
that essentially get rid of all of the
other mechanisms that deep networks have
for attending to long-range context and
that is the end of this lecture on
attention and memory and deep learning
thank you very much for your attention
you